over the weekend thousands of protestors
gathered at the March for truth to
protest president Trump's ties to Russia
as well as his withdrawal from the Paris
climate Accords this was a big big deal
and got me thinking since President
Trump took office it seems but there's a
new march or protest happening almost
every single day and it just gets so
overwhelming it gets hard to keep track
of them all but here's a new app it's
gonna help with so many protests going
on that's right it can be hard to keep
them all straight
but now there's March finder March
finder helps you find protests near you
anytime day or night just turn on your
location services then select the issues
that are important to you or use it the
way you use the rest of your apps for
anonymous sex it's never been easier to
get politically active with multiple
discs you share your passion for LGBT
rights religious freedom and environment
March finders democracy is unluckily so
are you
that guy had sex with a parrot saying
you're supposed to check these things
maybe put him out there he that parrot
might had sex with him it's a lot to
think about
yeah and where does the plant come into
it all there was a plant there as well I
listen I've been married a long time
you